bonsoir nous sommes le jeudi 31 mars
merci de nous retrouver pour cette
nouvelle édition du 7 8 le journal comme
chaque jour nous revenons sur votre
actualité locale on pourrait de nos
invités mais également des journalistes
de la rédaction tout de suite lé titre
de cette édition
aujourd'hui mouvement d'ampleur contre
le projet de loi travail de la ministre
myriam el khomri salariés étudiants et
syndicats étaient dans la rue pour
manifester demandé le retrait de la loi
le gouvernement sera-t-il marche arrière
analyses et réactions avec gentillesse
d'une année notre invité ce soir
ancien membre du parti socialiste et
hommes politiques yvelinois il est à
présent président du club politique et
république moderne 78 niveau raté
réaction à l'arrachage de mer de la
verrière annoncé sa démission hier soir
figure historique de la commune
il quitte son poste pour des raisons de
santé chez la majorité municipale
proposera la candidature de nelly du
tube lors du conseil municipal
d'installation du 14 avril au prochain
et enfin la chronique sport du jeudi
focus sur l'équipe de baseball les
cougars de montigny le bretonneux
l'équipe accueille nouvelles recrues
l'américain ryan juarez il vient
renforcer les rangs du club pour cette
saison nous l'avons rencontré et nous
recevons ce soir en plateau jean
philippe mallet bonsoir à vous vous
êtres dont vous êtes donc ex député de
la 11e circonscription des yvelines et
ex conseiller général du département
vous avez également été adjoint au maire
de bois d'arcy charge des finances et de
l'urbanisme
entre 2008 et 2012 aujourd'hui vous êtes
le président de république moderne dans
les yvelines un club politique dont le
président national et jean pierre
chevènement vous avez que j'étais le
parti socialiste à l'automne dernier
vous êtes donc un déçu le parti
socialiste si on peut dire ainsi
on sait la suite de
de mon âge mon engagement pardon y
compris lorsque j'étais député vous
savez si vous si vous avez relevé mais
vote pendant les deux années où j'ai été
député
j'ai exprimé à de nombreuses reprises
mon désaccord avec les projets de loi
qui était proposée par le gouvernement
et à commencer par le traité budgétaire
européen qui dès l'automne 2012 a été
proposé à l'assemblée nationale oh je
rappelle que françois hollande s'était
déclaré pendant sa campagne pour les
élections présidentielles opposé au
traité qui avait été signé par nicolas
sarkozy et angela merkel avaient dit
qu'ils renégocierait ce traité il ne l'a
pas fait et nous a proposé ce traité qui
était inacceptable
j'ai fait partie de la trentaine des
députés socialistes qui n'a pas voté ce
traité budget européen qui pour moi est
un petit peu la mère de mère des
batailles
la france s'est dit les mains parce ce
traité dans une orthodoxie budgétaire
qui est contre productive
au niveau économique qui a qui atteint
qui l'attend à la souveraineté populaire
et nationale donc pour moi c'est le fait
que je sois parti du parti socialiste
cet automne à l'automne 2015
c'est vraiment le prolongement de
désaccord profond avec le parti
socialiste je rappelle d'ailleurs que
j'avais n'avaient pas voté également la
première loi de libéralisation du droit
du travail
l'accord national interprofessionnel de
janvier février 2013 si vous en souvenez
qui avait été proposé également au vote
des députés qui était une première
mouture de libéralisation du code du
travail je ne l'avais pas voter non plus
vous avez donc à l'essai de rejoint donc
le club politique créé public moderne 70
nous y reviendrons plus dans quelques
instants avant cela on revient à la
cathine jour dont nous avons discuté
également ensemble donc la qualité du
jour c'est bien sûr la mobilisation
contre le projet de loi travail de la
ministre myriam el khomri qui a continué
ce jeudi 31 mars
malgré le mauvais temps les opposants à
la réforme du code du travail sont
mobilisés à paris et en province toute
la journée à trappes incarner une
cinquantaine de manifestants de la cgt
dans paris le départ de la journée
d'action était annoncée à 13h30 place
d'italie dans le xiiie arrondissement
arrondissement par bonds plusieurs
syndicats sont à l'initiative de cette
manifestation la cgt force ouvrière fsu
solidaires
les syndicats étudiants unef la cgt
dénonce l'ensemble du projet de loi
soutenu par le gouvernement écoute et
s'attaque encore une fois donc au droit
qu'ont les salariés dans le monde du
travail qui les protège un peu par
rapport aux ambitions des employeurs
donc qui a tendance finalement encore
une fois à casser les droits des
travailleurs notamment face à un
patronat qui est de plus en plus
agressif
c'est une manière de dire que de toute
façon les améliorations qui ont été
apportées suite au mouvement du 9 mars
ne nous conviennent pas et qu'on demande
et qu'on continuera de demander le
retrait pur et simple
la loi les conneries ils n'étaient pas
les seuls à se mobiliser après les 9 17
et 24 mars les étudiants continuent de
manifester contre la loi travail du
gouvernement les syndicats étudiants
effet nous appeler à nouveau un
rassemblement aujourd'hui ils ont tenu
une assemblée générale à saint quentin
en yvelines avant de rejoindre le défilé
parisien regardez ce reportage signé
mélanie poté était me lambert
c'est leur 4e rassemblement à l'appel du
collectif jaune 78e les lycéens et
étudiants y moi étaient réunis à
l'université versailles saint quentin ce
matin toujours dans leur ligne de mire
est la loi travail
aujourd'hui on est encore sur l'analyse
que ça satisfait pas du tout la jeunesse
et les préoccupations agenais sont pas
du tout pris en compte dans le cadre de
cette fois donc l'objectif pour
l'instant c'est obtenir un retrait de la
loi travail pour le mot négociation
impossible puisque c'est la base même du
projet de loi qui nous convient pas
c'est l'esprit même de cette loi qui
vise à libéraliser encore pointe un peu
plus le marché du travail qui vise à
augmenter la précarité des jeunes et
dans l'esprit même de cette langue pas
l'accepter
le 24 mars dernier myriam el khomri la
ministre du travail a présenté en
conseil des ministres une nouvelle
mouture du projet de loi
pas encore suffisant pour les syndicats
quand cette journée de mobilisation
nationale des étudiants ont été rejoints
par les cheminots de versailles
il faut faire absolument la jonction
étudiants lycéens et salariés en grève
côté hyper important c'est la clé de la
réussite pour faire vraiment vaciller ce
gouvernement et arrive à lui faire
retirer ce texte de loi qui absolument
mortifère pour le droit du travail mais
aussi par des biens placés nos propres
revendications de progrès social
l'exécution ont ensuite rejoint le
rassemblement parisien s'il estime ne
pas avoir obtenu satisfaction ils
envisagent de se rassembler à nouveau le
5 avril prochain date de l'examen
approfondi du texte par la commission
des affaires sociales jean philippe
manesse est loué à travail cristallise
beaucoup de mécontentement on l'a vu
dans le reportage pourtant elle a déjà
été remanié
certains disaient qu'elle a été vidé de
ses réformes essentielles
qu'en pensez-vous vous comprenez la
mobilisation générale en france
aujourd'hui
mais tout à fait bien entendu et c'est
une explication supplémentaire mon
départ du parti socialiste comment
rester dans un dans un parti qui qui n'a
pas compris que le code du travail le
droit du travail a été créé
historiquement c'est une donnée pour
protéger les salariés et non pas pour
pour pour créer de l'emploi
on est en train le gouvernement a décidé
mais effectivement de libéraliser
d'assouplir comme il dit le droit du
travail pour pour permettre aux chefs
d'entreprise d'avoir plus de facilité
dans les relations qu'ils ont avec leurs
salariés mais jean que j'entends bien
que les entreprises en particulier les
pme et tpe ont des difficultés et il ya
un travail à faire certainement pour
pour relancer relancer l'économie et
leur permettre de se développer
mais ce n'est pas en diminuant les
droits des travailleurs que quand qu'on
va y arriver ce qui compte d'abord c'est
les carnets de commandes des entreprises
vous savez s'agit pas de dire que les
chefs d'entreprise sont méchant ils
salariés sont gentils c'est pas simple
problème la question est dans une
entreprise
objectivement la relation entre le chef
d'entreprise et le salarié est
asymétrique mais flexibiliser l'emploi
qu'on voit nos voisins européens
aujourd'hui ça devient nécessaire
non pas forcément il faut il faut voir
je écouter la france s'est dotée
historiquement et de façon démocratique
d'un certain niveau 2 de droit du
travail de protection sociale de service
public tout ce qui fait que notre vie
est ce qu'il est et je reviens au traité
budgétaire européen car ne nous y
trompons pas l'actuel gouvernement se
fait le valais de la commission
européenne et va prendre ses ordres au
niveau européen ne nous y trompons pas
c'est présenté comme étant une réforme
du gouvernement il ne fait qu'exécuter
ce que demandent depuis des années la
commission européenne précisément il
faut lire les textes de de l'union
européenne là dessus qu'ils demandent
régulièrement est constamment à la
france de réduire sa voilure en terme de
protection sociale de service public
de quoi de l'ue travaillent et qui même
demande à revoir le salaire minimum
donc tous ces gens qui ont qui sont qui
se mobilise ses salariés ces jeunes les
classes populaires les classes moyennes
aussi ont tout à fait raison de se
mobiliser pour défendre leur défendre à
la fois leur droit mais surtout une
certaine façon de vivre en france une
certaine idée de ce qu'est la france
mais depuis longtemps marqué contre
l'europe aujourd'hui c'est vraiment
compliqué dans le contexte géopolitique
actuel il s'agit pas d'aller contre
l'europe
il s'agit pas de sortir de l'europe il
s'agit de dali vers une nouvelle
conception de l'europe et donc c'est moi
ce que je ce que je propose avec au côté
de jean pierre chevènement et et d'autre
ces deux de laisser respirer les nations
vous vous rendez compte qu'on a mis dans
la même monnaie l'euro
lorsqu'on a créé l'euro des économies
complètement différente des sociétés
complètement différente un ami de
l'allemagne la grèce par exemple et on
leur a demandé de marcher au même pas
m'écouter franchement c'est irréaliste
et ce genre de réflexion que vous
apportez avec le club poétique
république madame 78
réfléchissez tout à fait il ya ce
problème
économique lourd cette orthodoxie
budgétaire cette gang dans laquelle
l'union européenne nous enserre mais il
ya aussi un problème démocratique
enfin quelle atteinte à la souveraineté
à la souveraineté populaire et nationale
une fois de plus le peuple français a
décidé historiquement au long de son
histoire de se doter d'un certain mode
de vie d'un certain niveau de protection
sociale d'un certain niveau d'état et
nous avons voilà planant au dessus de
nous des commissaires européens qui nous
et nous voilà qui nous qui nous sommes
de 2,2 de réduire sa mais écouter les
français ne sont pas d'accord
la clac de réflexion at il donc la
réplique moderne at il écrit donc non
président et jean pierre chevènement a
été créée il ya peu ce que vous
ressentez déjà voilà un certain
d'accompagnement des hommes politiques
et yvon dans votre sens qui ne veulent
plus de clivage dropt droite gauche mais
qui veulent repenser globalement j cp t2
français a bien sûr je pense que mais
vous savez il ya toute une partie de la
gauche d'ailleurs je m'en disent aussi
vous savez je suis parti je suis sorti
du parti socialiste mais je ne suis pas
non plus dans cette gauche là la gauche
de la gauche qui trop souvent pleurniche
est pas son temps faire la morale aux
français en disant que c'est mal de
voter front national mais écoutez
franchement il faut quand même
s'interroger
d'un point de vue du gauche quand on
voit les classes populaires est de plus
en plus les classes moyennes qui votent
front national c'est à dire qu' il n'y a
pas une offre politique aujourd'hui à
gauche qui satisfasse les français nos
concitoyens c'est ça la vraie question
or nous n'avons pas et nous n'avons pas
su jusqu'à présent su proposer une offre
politique qui intègre le logiciel
national et républicain
nous n'avons pas su le faire ils le
front national a cannibalisé l'idée
nationale je rappelle quand même qu
historiquement la souveraineté populaire
nationale la gauche pendant très
longtemps incarné on a décidé d'oublier
sa re lisez les textes du parti
socialiste depuis trente ans la nation
ça n'existe plus je ne caricature pas la
nation n'existe plus lisez
écoutez les dirigeants socialistes lisez
les textes depuis depuis 30 ans l'europe
c'est très bien bon il faut aller vers
l'europe
le local c'est bien on pas plus la
nation nous rejoint justement sur le
local en référence au mouvement de grève
qui a lieu aujourd'hui en solidarité
avec ce mouvement la ville de la
verrière s'est mobilisé également
aujourd'hui la restauration scolaire la
halte garderie les crèches les
installations sportives mais aussi les
services administratifs de la ville
étaient fermées toute la journée écouter
à l'arrachage qui soutenaient ce
mouvement justement la verrière il ya
beaucoup de salariés qui seront sans
doute engrais dans leur entreprise à la
manifestation
nous accompagnons les salariés
municipaux de la commune qui seront
mobilisés parce que nous sommes inquiets
effectivement de cette loi qui pour nous
une loi dangereuse difficile dans une
ville où les gens sont sensibles à
l'évolution du code du travail
il faut arrêter de considérer tout est
normal qu'il n'y a pas d'issue que les
décisions sont prises on plus haut
niveau et que c'est comme ça je pense
qu'effectivement à tous les niveaux des
habitants mais aussi les élus c'est
notre responsabilité de dire stop stop
on n'en veut pas et toujours hier soir
s'il annonce n'était pas prévu elle
n'aura finalement pas surpris le maire
de la verrière annoncé donc qu'il ait
quitté son poste à l'arrachage 58 ans
vient de remettre sa démission au préfet
d evennou pour raisons de santé wilfried
est riche et pour ce reportage
j'ai les décisions difficiles pour moi
vraiment parce que j
la rumeur était persistante ces derniers
jours c'est désormais officiel alain
ajaj quitte son poste de maire de la
verrière c'était lors du conseil
municipal mercredi soir qu'il a choisi
de l'annoncé non sans émotion des
raisons de santé l'ont poussé à s'y
résoudre
comme toujours dans ce moment là on
espère que les choses vont s'améliorer
s'arranger c'est pas tout à fait le kg
la situation de santé encore besoin
d'attention de soins est en tout cas
incompatible avec
le rythme de vie qu'imposent les
fonctions de maire dans une petite
commune faut être extrêmement présent il
faut être à l'écouté et puis moi je ne
sais pas faire autrement que ça c'est en
2012 après le départ de pierre c'est
lincourt élu depuis 29 ans qu'alain ajaj
devient mère il s'impose rapidement dans
ce rôle en 2014 il obtient près de 60%
des suffrages lors de l'élection
municipale
déjà affaibli en raison de sa santé il
prend l'année suivante plusieurs mois de
repos mais dès son retour il s'engage
sur d'importants dossiers rénovation du
quartier du bois de l'étang et
développement de celui des bécanes je
n'avais pas vocation à être mère 36
mandat c'est pas ma conception
je pense que il faut laisser la place
aux jeunes le moment venu j'aurais
évidemment apprécié de boire finir ce
mandat notant que c'est un mandat c'est
déterminant tu me suis impliqué engagé
dans beaucoup de projets pour l'avenir
je les verrai autrement alain hajjaj
restera conseiller municipal nelly duthu
devrait lui succéder le 14 avril
prochain lors du nouveau scrutin interne
aux élus les habitants ne devront pas
retourner aux urnes
c'est un maire qui a qui s'est beaucoup
battu pour sa ville qui très très
présent qui a travaillé
sans compter faut quand même le dire est
dans l'intérêt de sa population parmi
les réactions politiques celle de son
homologue des républicains à elle en
cours via twitter ou encore celle de la
responsable socialiste du département et
lui attraper qui siège à ses côtés à
l'agglomération de saint quentin en
yvelines d'un politique avec qui j'ai
pris plaisir à travailler qu'un homme à
la fois particulièrement brillant
intelligent et un grand événement
vraiment proche des gens donc il y avait
un travail qui était très très utile et
très agréable avec lui il a une vision
il sait ce qu'il veut faire et pas
toujours le cas de tous les hommes
politiques faut bien reconnaître on a
beaucoup d'hommes politiques sont des
gestionnaires ne s'était pas
gestionnaire simplement quelqu'un qui
avait une vision sur quelques qu'il
voulait pour la tromperie thouaré pour
les habitants qui ont péri thouars qui
ont tous les habitants de la verrière
viennent de recevoir dans leur boîte aux
lettres un courrier les informant de ce
départ jean claude mallet vous
connaissiez alain ajaj est ce que
c'était vraiment compliqué à gérer une
démission comme ceux ci en cours de
mandat ont très certainement pour lui
mais moi je j'ai travaillé avec alain
jaj et je suis intervenu lorsque j'étais
députés dans l'hémicycle pour pour les
projets d'aménagement urbain à linge âge
par les deux des bécanes par exemple ce
sont des dossiers que j'ai soutenu on a
travaillé aussi il était il est attaché
au à des projets de développement avec
le mali quelqu'un que j'apprécie
beaucoup et qui a beaucoup donné pour
pour sa ville
moi je salue vraiment le maire l'eau qui
s'est beaucoup engagé qui a donné de son
temps ou aux autres et et aux habitants
des verrières merci beaucoup à jean
philippe mallet alors je rappelle que le
club politique république moderne va au
cours de l'année animé deux autres
colloques de succès à troisième qui
s'est tenue à versailles le 22 mars il
voulait retrouver plus d'informations
n'hésitez pas à consulter le site
internet république moderne point fr
vous y retrouver toutes les actualités
merci à vous merci d'être venu à jean
philippe mallet merci et aujourd'hui les
enseignants étaient appelés eux
aussi à se mobiliser dans les yvelines
quelques chiffres concernant cette
mobilisation 6 21% du personnel des
collèges a pris part aux revendications
se jetter 31 mars dans les lycées c'est
deux points 70 % d'entre eux qui les ont
rejoints et 10 25% de grévistes dans les
écoles primaires et maternelles et tout
autre sujet maintenant nous avons parlé
d'économie de nombreux grands groupes
sont installés à saint quentin en
yvelines ils ont juste ouais ils ont
choisi de bâtir des campus des lieux de
vie pour les salariés au mode de travail
collaboratif les atouts de ces campus
sont nombreux fanny bourdillon nous en
dit plus
elle a visité le campus du crédit
agricole appelé skypark basé à
guyancourt regarder ce sont les premiers
à avoir installé leur campus à saint
quentin en yvelines
à la fin des années 70 aujourd'hui le
campus du groupe crédit agricole
appelée skypark évolue encore un nouveau
bâtiment a été construit pour répondre à
un enjeu majeur doubler leurs effectifs
avant la fin de l'année nous sommes
d'ores et déjà à peu près de 2800
personnes regroupées sur le campus de
skate park au sein du groupe crédit
agricole
nous allons très fortement dans les mois
à venir jusqu'en septembre 2010 est
augmenté nos effectifs puisque nous
serons à peu près 5000 un petit peu
moins 1 4800 personnes qui travailleront
sur le campus skypark évidemment ça
signifie que nous avons construit des
immeubles à nous en rénovant d'autres et
puis également effectivement nous
augmentons les infrastructures skate
parc regroupe désormais six immeubles
sur une surface de 11 hectares c'est
aussi 250 salles de réunions des langues
un gymnase des restaurants et depuis peu
une application smartphone qu'une
application smartphone qui permet
d'avoir des informations générales sur
la vie du campus qui permet de se
localiser à l'intérieur du campus je
suis dans un bâtiment où j'ai besoin de
chercher une salle dans un autre
bâtiment avec lequel je ne suis pas
familier
l'application vraiment on a directement
à la salle de réunion semble je suis
obligé de tourner dans les étages avant
de la trouver
les nouvelles technologies sont au coeur
de ce campus et les avantages sont
nombreux
travail collaboratif et participatif ou
encore lieu de vie agréable pour les
salariés aujourd'hui les grands groupes
copie tout des campus étudiant c'est un
campus ouvert à prenant un peu à la mode
américaine des campus américaine de la
silicon valley des grandes entreprises
parce que ici si vous voulez c'est le
campus technologique du groupe crée des
récollets ça et donc nous amenons des
nouvelles technologies le numérique nous
transforme et doit transformer
transformer également les mentalités et
le campus à cette notion là on n'est pas
des étudiants au loin de là mais on
aimerait bien avoir cette approche
ouverte dynamique qui change de la
banque 30-17 traditionnelle et vous
voyez nous sommes ici dans un lieu qui
s'appelle un lange
vous ne pouvez pas vous imaginer que
vous êtes dans une entreprise du cac 40
renault airbus ou boeing
de nombreuses entreprises ont adopté la
même dynamique que le crédit agricole
faisant de saint-quentin-en-yvelines une
ville de campus tout autre sujet le
navigateur louis burton était à
coignières aujourd'hui le skipper avec
jusqu'à l'âge de 17 ans à la selle les
bandes près de rambouillet il a appris à
naviguer au centre de voile de saint
quentin en yvelines avec son sponsor
bureau vallée il va à la rencontre des
clients et des passionnés de sports
nautiques
louis burton a déjà réalisé la route du
rhum la jacques vabre il participera
pour la deuxième fois à la prochaine
course du vendée globe où les coudes au
micro de patrick jacques de dixmude au
vendée globe 2012 jeu
on s'attendait pas à ça je m'attendais
pas à ce que ça s'arrête au bout de cinq
jours c'est une préparation très longue
c'est beaucoup d'investissement donc
c'est toujours très bizarre quand ça
s'arrête si vite donc voilà je parle on
est confiant je suis serein avec le
bateau maintenant je sais aussi que un
vendée globe c'est c'est quelque chose
qui se
qui doit se mériter de gagner et que
rien n'est fait tant qu'on n'a pas
bouclé le parcours et pour la 8e édition
du vendée globe le départ sera donné le
6 novembre 2016 en baie des sables
d'olonne et comme tous les jeudis il
nous a rejoint sur ce plateau pour sa
chronique sport je vais bien sûr parler
de michael almy d'euros notre
journaliste sportif bonsoir mutuelle
je crois que vous allez nous parler de
baseball dans votre chronique du jour je
crois que vous avez lu mes fiches avant
le début de l'émission
un sixième sens pour les croyances pas
alors aujourd'hui je vais vous parler du
nouveau joueurs des cougars de
montigny-le-bretonneux ryan juares cet
américain de 27 ans a posé ses valises
dans la ville saint-quentinoise il ya
quelques semaines et ce n'est pas un
second couteau flora ni la joue en
division 1 sied à la colle state
university northridge la jouer à berlin
en troisième division l'australie à
canberra et en première division en
belgique
le californien n'a pas hésité à signer
pour le définit et mon teint on écoute
pour vous une bonne équipe nous avons eu
une super semaine de stage la semaine
dernière à montpellier j'ai pu voir
l'expérience de l'équipe le groupe qui
était en place et j'ai pu voir que
j'avais pris la bonne décision en venant
ici
du côté de mon team retenu l'équipe
senior est évidemment ravi de l'avoir
recruté les cougars qui vise clairement
la montée en première division cette
saison devrait avoir besoin de ryan
juares pour remplir leur objectif
aujourd'hui c'est nécessaire d'avoir un
étranger si on veut viser le plus haut
niveau notamment la d1 c'est notre
objectif notre mieux nous envie notre
ambition cette année oui c'est
aujourd'hui c'est nécessaire d'avoir un
starter est un lanceur qui va pouvoir
prendre le départ le
les dessus en tout cas sur le premier
match ce qu'on a toujours deux matchs
des journées de matches et si on peut
s'assurer au moins une victoire avec un
lanceur étrangers c'est essentiel je le
disais précédemment réel juarez c'est de
l'expérience en 2014 il a été l'un des
meilleurs jours de berlin avec des
statistiques impressionnantes
le nouveau manager des cougars nous
présente ses qualités il tient vraiment
son rôle sur le monticule il est à
l'aise françois qui a une grande
expérience et l'a quand même fait partie
de l'équipe nationale des philippines
qui a été jouée la vente classique c'est
compétition mondiale il ya quelques
quelques mois donc on sent vraiment
qu'il tient son rôle puisqu'il a à coeur
de le faire il a envie de vraiment de
nous apporter son expérience et
aujourd'hui on est sur deux qui veut
qu'il va faire de grandes choses avec
nous rassurez-nous qu'elle a rien n'est
pas venu en france pour faire du
tourisme du savon il va peut-être faire
du shopping sur sont en ligne mais en
tout cas il est très professionnel il
veut conquérir le stade jean maréchal et
des montigny à monter en première
division cette année c'est évidemment de
faire monter l'équipe en première
division car je pense que cette équipe
est assez bonne pour jouer dans cette
division et j'ai besoin de les aider
j'ai entendu que l'année dernière n'en
était pas loin de cet objectif mais ils
n'ont pas réussi à monter
je pense que bientôt ils seront à ce
niveau avec la politique les mises en
place les gars peuvent faire le travail
ils sont prêts à y aller
malheureusement florane on ne devrait
pas pouvoir admirer très longtemps ce
talent brut il devrait repartir dans six
mois en australie pour poursuivre sa
carrière
raison de plus pour ne pas rater le
premier match à domicile des cougars de
montier bretonne le thé le dans votre
agenda florane lésigny monte à 1 contre
l'équipe fédérale de toulouse le 17
avril prochain
on vient c'est un rendez vous que je ne
manquerai pas on reste dans le sport
américain en sol américain
des tanks et les templiers par bonjour
on se rend à danser là le match qu'il ne
faudra pas perdre pour les templiers les
élans comtois qui avait très bien débuté
leur saison avec une victoire contre les
gladiateurs de la queue-en-brie début
février n'y arrive plus les footballeurs
de saint quentin ont perdu quatre matchs
consécutifs et il doit se ressaisir
contre la courneuve le flash ne son côté
l'une des meilleures équipes du
championnat élite avec deux victoires en
quatre matches disputés les templiers
auront besoin du soutien de leurs
supporters pour créer l'exploit au
complexe sportif europe ce samedi
inventeur un beau rendez-vous en
perspective merci à vous mais quelle on
vous retrouve dans quelques instants
votre talk à la dream team bas nouvelle
fois faire le show dans six ans par les
sports ou 4 niqueurs débattront sur la
saison des cougars de montiers oise le
le boxeur sur le boxeur a dit la move a
dit qui vient d'elancourt mais également
sur le duel grégory baugé françois
pervis en cyclisme sur piste pour une
place à rio et bien comme d'habitude un
très beau programme merci michael la
semaine prochaine on va rester un petit
peu avant de parler sport avant de
fermer ce journal ce mardi le vélodrome
national inauguré vélocité une
exposition permanente pensé par deux
historiens du score l'exposition se
concentre sur le vélodrome dans
l'histoire du cyclisme
des photos des affiches mais aussi des
vélos sont à découvrir je vous propose
d'écouter thomas bauer il était au micro
de manip ok c'est le commissaire de
l'exposition
ça s'adresse à tout le monde évidemment
on passionné de cyclisme au premier chef
puisque ils vont y voir des images
anciennes
ils vont y retrouver des des éléments
mécaniques des éléments raid de
règlement d aspect vestimentaire qui
vont les subs qui vont les anime et on
va dire où les subjuguer et puis
évidemment c'est une ouverture
culturelle pour rouler pour le grand
public qui va découvrir un sport qu'ils
ne soupçonnaient même pas et une
dernières informations avant de refermer
ce journal les cars périer qui assurent
60 % du service des transports au ski
bus reconduisent leur mouvement de grève
demain vendredi 1er avril c'est à
présent la fin de cette édition merci de
nous avoir suivis demain vous retrouvez
wilfried des riches y pour l'essentiel
de l'actu pour ma part je vous retrouve
est lundi pour une nouvelle édition du
journal je vous souhaite donc une
excellente soirée et un agréable
week-end